this is Startalk this one Chris Emmett
and he says how does art inspire
scientists to think outside of the box
and vice versa so for you how does art
push your boundaries your perspectives
further out and for you how does science
push your artistic boundaries is I know
you did what was it the monolith of the
Phobos Ryan monolith the Phobos is our
record title yeah so like I mean clearly
there's an association there for both of
you so yeah I mean for me fundamentally
music is mass I mean you know there's
basically XYZ axis of the time in which
the note is placed the pitch of the note
and then the the volume of that note I
mean Tambor could be arguably a fourth
axis but I mean it's very mathematical
it's easy to chart music on a graph and
so you know I think any musician who
stops to think about it would would
would really you know think of of melody
as a kind of audio geometry you know so
I mean it is mass and most of the people
that I know who are very mathematically
minded are huge music nerds you know my
friend Erik Weinstein he's a famous
mathematician physicist economist you
know he all he ever wants to talk to me
about is like whether Robert Johnson is
cooler than Roy Harper's well for me the
the your mask you asked me this question
I know that I'll just say that I love
space art I love space art I love what
space art is do the scenes that they
create
you know I need them at NASA don't you
because often you have to visualize
illustrations that I noticed when you I
mean you can't take a picture of an
exoplanet but but NASA releases these
sort of Illustrated what if it you know
what if lot of we're sitting on you know
Titan or something right oh yes but I'm
talking about the genuine space artists
who just do it for a living and I'm so
I'm this is another one of those things
I did
that you know I'm very happy I did I
didn't don't think anybody was doing it
before I did but on our Cyclops website
that we set up for the public that is
you know me and the Cassini imaging team
there's a special section there that is
devoted to space artists you know just
what the scenes they've depicted of
Saturn or we actually go beyond Saturn
but the Rings and Titan and and I love
looking at those and I love looking at
you know just what the scenes on
exoplanets because that's a way to be
there you know these people painting
you're friended of the rings of Saturn
the view of looking at those
irregularities that are like how high
are they oh the fabulous okay wonderful
that you brought that up you know we
found in the Rings we found this
incredible thing I mean the Rings are
only thirty feet thick okay that they're
so why they're bigger than the earth
like much bigger right I mean they would
fit in from end to end between the earth
and the moon yeah I love it and then we
found on the edge of the Bering and we
also extend a similar thing on the edge
of a gap in the outer a ring we found
these mountainous waves of rubble that
extend two and three miles high is that
the resonance with the moons right yeah
it's a little complicated in one case
that moon is nearby and it actually
because it's on an inclined orbit it
draws the particles out of the plane not
complicated it's just like pushing a kid
on a swing and every time you push it
goes farther right okay except that
what's complicated is because of that
pushing on the swing the orbits of the
particles become eccentric and that
means in certain regions of the orbit
they get squeezed together and that has
to push them higher right on the outer
edge of the B ring these things of these
rubble piles these rubble mountains are
very irregular looking but they're high
so imagine this you've got a sheet of
material that's 30 feet thick
something coming out that's miles high
and I often said in public how fast I'm
spinning like 40,000 miles an hour yeah
right and so so you say you'd like to
take a craft there one day but are you
just being hyperbolic because I mean
that sounds like a very dangerous place
to drive it I don't care just this is
just like all in my mind's eye I mean
possible to actually have a cello craft
that close to these spinning yes three
rings yeah oh my god that sounds sports
to me you could be over the Rings you
know and if you're really close to the
Rings the Rings would look like they
extend to infinity to you effectively go
solo and imagine you're flying you're
flying you're flying and then you come
across a wall of rubble that's two or
three miles high so I the artist who did
this I think had heard me say that and
he wanted to paint it so we went back
and forth as to what it should look like
and it's a Chevy Nova great name for the
cards oh by the way the connection
between art design